hi guys how's it going this is ideas of
Ice and Fire since my last doom talk
video went so well where I was just kind
of talking to you guys not really in a
scripted manner I decided that I would
make another one and this time I'm going
to focus on the butt Larry and jihad and
also I think I'm gonna get into some of
my thoughts on AI in the real world so
the butler in jihad in the first chapter
of doom is described as the great revolt
that took away a crutch the Butler in
Jihad was basically the philosophical
struggle of people versus other people
who had come to utilize computers as a
substitute or a crutch for developing
their own abilities so basically before
the Butler in Jihad everyone was
dependent upon machines thinking
machines kind of like how we are now
think about what would happen if the
internet went away our society would
pretty much crumble would it not so we
are totally dependent on thinking
machines and another level of this this
is also in the very first chapter of
Dune and I'm gonna read this entire
quote once men turned their thinking
over to machines in the hope that this
would set them free
but that only permitted other men with
machines to enslave them thou shalt not
make a machine in the likeness of a
man's mind Paul quoted right out of the
butler Ian jihad and the orange Catholic
Bible she said but what the Ossie Bible
should have said is thou shalt not make
a machine to counterfeit a human mind so
the idea is if everyone is dependent on
making machines that means that the
person that has control over those
thinking machines has immense way over
everyone else so once we gave ourselves
over to machines and hoping this would
set us free
but that only permitted other men with
machines to enslave us this is the
struggle of man versus man and that key
fact is basically the reason that I
struggle so much with the brine Herbert
interpretation of the but Larry and
jihad because it's very much about evil
machines that enslave humanity
and it's not about that struggle of it's
not about the struggle of humanity which
is what Doom is has always been about
it's always been about humans so the
butler in Jihad lasted two generations
this was from 200 BG to 108 BG right so
by 108 BG they had expunged all the
thinking machines from the known
universe and BG just stands for before a
guilt but it's not actually before the
guilt because they did exist but it's
before their monopoly on space trouble
so the result oh the Butler in Jihad
ultimately is that there are no more
thinking machines they can't even have
the simplest of thinking machines not
even calculators all of its banned so
it's it's very shaded but you know the
interesting thing is the god emperor
later on doesn't seem to really care
about the butler in jihad that much he's
kind of breaking the butler in jihad
secretly so that's also very interesting
and you do have the friend worlds like
the exeunt who were they kind of make
gadgets and devices and then you have
those lilacs ooh who are kind of like
the biological technology but both of
these groups they kind of play with they
kind of push the bounds of the Butler in
Jihad they they push it sometimes they
even cross it personally I'm much more
worried about something like what
happened in dune happening then
terminator because you think about an
artificial intelligence and you think
about a person we behave the way we are
and we have the emotions that we have
and we are the we are the way we are
because of millions of years of
evolution by natural selection we
evolved to survive in certain
environments and that gives us pretty
much all that we are but if we design an
artificial intelligence we don't have to
give it any of that we don't have to
give it desire we don't have to give it
hatred we don't have to give it anger we
don't have to give it any of these
things that make humans humans it's
possible to have an artificial
intelligence that is intelligent but
that is not like us and that's why I
like what the Reverend
mother said so much in doom she said the
OSI Bible should have said you shouldn't
make a machine to counterfeit a human
mind and artificial intelligence doesn't
have to be an exact copy of everything
that is human right but still the
problem lies and the problem is once the
people are dependent on our official
intelligence the people that are in
charge of that artificial intelligence
the people that are programming that
artificial intelligence have huge sway
on us think about all the stuff that's
already going on with these huge
companies like Facebook and Google and
Apple they're all spying on us they all
have algorithms that are constantly
gathering data about us knowledge truly
is power and that is a lot of power to
wield but the thing is in our society
today like once the momentum is built up
how can you go back from that like we
can't just give up this technology now
it would kind of ruin society like I
said if the internet went away we would
lose so much and that also happened in
dune after the butlering in Jihad
humanity's quality of life dropped
significantly it was really bad for a
long time but what it did was it created
the need for humans to become better
they needed to like perform the complex
calculations that the computers could so
that led to the rise of the guild and I
led to the rise of the beginning Jesuit
and that led to the rise of the space
and guilt who were just like pure
mathematics what I think is interesting
though is that later the second kind of
viewed prescience like humanity viewed
Thinking Machines Leto saw prescience as
the death of humanity as the bane of
humanity and so in the Golden Path part
of it was making humanity immune to
pressings he didn't want humanity he
didn't want any one person to be able to
affect humanity on such a large scale
with presence he knew that that would
lead to ultimate destruction so I think
that kind of the message that we're
supposed to get from the butler
jihad is that sometimes human ingenuity
can lead to laziness and laziness is the
downfall of humanity this can be our
downfall our technology can be our
downfall if we if we use it as a crutch
ultimately I think later saw that
anything that's used as a crutch
is ultimately is could lead to the
downfall of humanity he knew the
monopoly on spice would eventually end
when he's talking about the deep
treasures that are hidden under Arrakis
I think what Leto was talking about was
the worms he knew that the worms would
leave the planet and populate other
planets that's what he was saying there
my opinion what later I wanted was for
people to live in their instincts again
and they couldn't do that with prescient
so in the doom books they obviously do
still have machines they don't have
Thinking Machines like I said there are
the axioms that produce all types of
devices like poison supers which detect
poison they've got like glow globes
they've got shields but none of these
things think so they the Butler in Jihad
doesn't apply to them so yeah like I
said humanity had to improve themselves
so basically humans are the new thinking
machines humans filled all those they
use people as tape recorders they use
people to transmit secret messages
without them even knowing it perhaps the
Mentats like i mentioned before are of
course the human computers invade they
can compute even faster than the
greatest of the faking machines
and speaking of min tats another way
people kind of moved beyond machines is
drugs
the mint effort instants have Sappho
juice which increases their ability to
think and then there is of course the
spice melange which heightens awareness
and it is also a geriatric substance and
yes that is the proper use of the word
geriatric I've seen some of you comment
in the comments before that I was using
geriatric incorrectly no even in the
book it says the geriatrics bias what
Frank Herbert is saying in dune is that
it refers to aging so the spice is also
heavily relied upon by people like the
guild it's just an all-around human
enhancing drug
but with one big caveat and that is that
it will kill you if you stop taking it
so you better make sure you have a
steady supply of it so basically what
the society and doing had to do was they
had to trade in certain things for other
things without the benefit of thinking
machines and I would assume that in some
ways it is worse but it seems like most
people in the Dune universe get why the
but Larry and jihad was needed and they
feel like it's better now than it was
back then
the bottom line is I do think technology
is definitely a crutch a lot of people
think we're getting stupider I don't
think we're getting stupider I think
we're getting more distracted and more
dependent on technology I'm dependent I
have to watch myself because I type a
lot and the autocorrect is totally a
crutch it's like I forget how to spell
certain words because I'm so dependent
on autocorrect a lot of times when I'm
typing on the computer so when I
actually have to write something it's
like I had a thing for a little bit
longer how do I spell this I think that
maybe perhaps what they did in dune by
expunging all Thinking Machines might
have been a little bit too extreme maybe
humans could have learned to better
themselves in balance with Thinking
Machines I think that's what I think
that's the direction that we should move
toward because I think that AI could
potentially have so many so many
benefits for the world and if I think
humans could mature enough and if we
could evolve pass our childhood phase
and move into the adult phase as a
species then maybe we could live with AI
and maybe not destroy ourselves in the
process but you see that's the thing we
have to mature before we get to the
point where it's too late and see that's
the thing if we're already there and
then we're talking about oh let's try
mature it's gonna be too late and maybe
it's already too late maybe the momentum
is just built up too far and we're just
not mature enough and we're already in
it because in a lot of ways it already
feels like we're inside of an episode of
black mirror that's why I think that
show is so freakin terrifying and so
amazing at least the second two seasons
the first two seasons before Netflix got
a hold of it aren't aren't as good but
those second two seasons of black mirror
are freaking amazing and I love how they
explore
the idea of consciousness and in might
being black Mir does it way better job
than in West world with it like black
mirror is really exploring what it means
to be conscious and like what if you
come up with conscious machines then
what but there's there it's so much to
think about and these are extremely
complicated questions and I don't think
that we're at a point in our society
where we're even ready to talk about
this we have so many people in our
society that just flat out reject
science and don't even care like our
government is so anti science right now
in the United States it's just
ridiculous and there is a lot to be
fearful about I think we have so much
capability in so much power and in the
wrong hands this power can be
devastating and I guess we'll see what
happens in the future but it's very easy
to be cynical it's very easy to think
that maybe something like the boat
Libyan jihad is gonna happen we're gonna
have to get rid of all the thinking
machines and we're just gonna be hurled
back centuries as far as technology goes
I'm gonna have to reinvent ourselves as
people maybe that is what's necessary or
maybe we will inevitably be destroyed by
thinking machines maybe that'll happen
maybe we'll destroy ourselves there's so
many ways we could lead ourselves into
oblivion and I think misuse of AI is one
of those possibilities and I think the
worst-case scenario would be not humans
being extinct but us being us just
living in a society where the bottom of
us are just like totally enslaved I know
some people are gonna say that's now but
like really just like totally enslaved
I'm talking about like a 1984 situation
where it's like ultimate technocracy and
and you've got you've got the elites on
the top that are that are in control of
the technology and they're controlling
us and we're just all on the bottom we
have no say-so
we can't escape it because a society a
civilization is so advanced that
anything that you do is monitored
anything that you do is detect it
beforehand and calculate it beforehand
there there is no revolution in a
situation like this how do you revolt
against something like that so something
so immensely powerful that's what's
really scary to me when you have a
government that just knows
everything about you and then also what
scares me too and this is weird is that
these new doors these new doors that
amazon has where the person can unlock
your door from the inside it's like
don't put technology and you're freaking
in your in your door I mean cuz once
once the government can just hack your
door and lock you inside of your house I
mean oh my god and then Amazon Alexa you
want you want to put a bunch of like a
bunch of audio recorders in your house
that record everything you say and do I
know my phone is fried my phone is
sitting right here in the desk I know my
phone is probably I know it is recording
everything that I'm saying but you just
want more of that I don't need any of
that stuff yeah so but maybe that's just
my paranoia but I think that to wrap all
this up but Larry and jihad was about
men in control of Technology subjugating
other men with that technology that's
what it was about I feel as though
personally I feel as though Brian Herman
and Kevin J Anderson failed with their
Butler in Jihad books I don't think that
was what was going on but no hate if you
like those books then that's totally
fine thank you guys for watching make
sure you like and subscribe if you
enjoyed this dune talk video and if you
want more just let me know and I'll make
more videos where it's just me talking
you guys about doing because I can talk
about doom for hours it's my it's my
favorite science fiction series ever I
mean I like I like a lot of books I like
a lot of fantasy and sci-fi but doing
it's definitely number one as far as
sci-fi concerns and also if you like the
foundation check out my most recent
foundation video I talked about the mule
who is a very interesting character and
I talked about early in this video how
Leto didn't want a person to affect
humanity in such a mass level that's
kind of what the mule does you have this
guy named Harry seldom who had this plan
for Humanity and the mule disrupts his
plan because he can affect a much people
on a large scale so check that out if
you want some more classic science
fiction Asimov definitely inspired Frank
Herbert thank you guys for watching I'll
see you in the next video
[Music]
you
you